a school district in california has
suspended a teacher accused of
radicalizing his students with antifa
propaganda that's after the
investigative group project veritas
released undercover footage
i have 180 days to turn him into
revolutionaries how do you do that how
do you scare me
i i probably uh as far left as you can
go like why aren't people just like
taking a bite like why and you know we
have historically
taking up arms like against the state i
have an antifa flag on my on my wall um
and a student complained about that and
you said it made them feel uncomfortable
well this is meant to make fascists feel
uncomfortable so if you feel
uncomfortable i i don't really know what
to do like maybe you shouldn't be
aligning with the values that this is
antithetical too
now gabrielle gaip who was uh seen in
that video right there works at a high
school in sacramento after that clip
surfaced he was placed on leave for
violating political action guidelines
and local authorities say they plan to
fire him now
well after the video guy did in fact
apologize saying that teachers should
not be sharing their personal beliefs
but for many outraged parents that
simply wasn't enough and they certainly
didn't hold back at a school board
meeting
this is evil it's darkness it is hell
and these are criminals for abusing our
children maybe we should get a class
action lawsuit endangerment of a child
you guys would have done nothing because
you did nothing when these students
complained you stand by this man
preaching antifa and communism in our
classrooms a disgrace
this is just too much this man being
fired is not everything that we want we
need our rights back as parents it is
your responsibility
to know what he's teaching
and it's been going on for years and you
allowed it to happen you're going to be
held accountable this this is because of
you
okay
gabriel guy
is a symptom not the sickness
we heard from legal analyst jennifer
demaster now she says that better
background checks are needed before
hiring educators
specifically in the public school system
i mean we're seeing over and over uh
these these public school teachers that
are aligning with these very very
dangerous ideologies being allowed to
teach children he wasn't hiding his
beliefs if he was that obvious about uh
about his his beliefs and what he was
doing i guarantee you that students were
already talking to their parents and
that parents were already complaining to
the district to the school board trying
to get something done and nothing was
ever done i think more of that is going
to come out because in the public
schools it's different for private
schools than it is for public schools
private schools have a lot more leeway
in how they want to interview people
every employer these days looks up
social media looks up uh what you say
they have a right to choose not to hire
you but in the government you know
they're supposed to do that more in
government positions like a public
school teacher and so they should be
looking into these accounts and seeing
that what's what's startling is the vast
number of public school teachers that
have such outrageous extremist left-wing
beliefs
that continue to get hired
you